Ok.
Thì đầu tiên thì như anh chia sẻ thì hôm
nay à Long có bảo anh là anh muốn được
cho nhóm các bạn thằng điện Quang đền hô
các cách bảo vệ một cái đồ án đúng
không? Thì như hồi trước anh hay làm cho
ở bên trường thì sẽ là lúc mà các bạn
đang thuyết trình thì các thầy cô cũng
sẽ có hỏi luôn. Nói chung là đôi khi nó
sẽ hơi bị mất mạch cảm xúc một tí. Nhưng
mà thực tế thực tế thì cái mục đích của
cái bảo vệ đồ án nhá. Đấy theo như các
thầy cô nghĩ và theo như anh nghĩ thì nó
sẽ phải làm hơi mất cảm xúc. Tức là sao?
Nghĩa là nó sẽ không có chuyện mà các
bạn lên thuyết trình tràng xong rồi các
thầy cô vỗ tay xong rồi chúng ta đi
xuống ân mình không phải mà các bạn đúng
nghĩa phải là bảo vệ. Tức là các thầy cô
có thể nói đúng hoặc thậm chí nói sai
nhá. Kiểu nói cố tình hỏi mấy câu sai,
hỏi mấy câu nó vô lý để các bạn phải
hoảng hiện lại được, phải nói lại được,
phải bảo vệ được cái sản phẩm của mình.
Đấy, thế nên là sẽ không sẽ không có
chuyện là kiểu khá xương sẻ theo kiểu là
các bạn cứ thuyết trình đúng theo kịch
bạc xong rồi các thầy cô cũng sẽ trả lời
đúng theo thịch bạc. không không có kiểu
đấy nên là các bạn cứ nên sẵn sàng không
bị tâm lý các thứ được không ạ?
Ok bắt đầu về chương trình đầu tiên các
bạn cứ giới thiệu các thử nhá.
Dạ à xin phép em thức à em xin phép giới
thiệu một chút ạ. Thì nhóm em là nhóm
G18
nhóm em gồm năm người thì em là leader
của nhóm G18.
Và dự án của bọn em là SL secondhand
market platform for họ lạc student. Đây
là một dự án, một nền tảng ờ chợ trao
đổi đồ cũ dành cho sinh viên Hòa Lạc
và mục tiêu là giúp mua bán, trao đổi đồ
cũ một cách tiện lợi và minh bạch hơn.
Ờ các tính năng nổi bật ở đây là đăng
bán tìm kiếm sản phẩm nhanh chóng, tích
hợp bản đồ, có thể chat trực tiếp với
seller, hỗ trợ ờ ờ hệ thống có tích hợp
đánh giá và à xác nhận giao dịch dễ
dàng.
Về bối cảnh về bối cảnh của dự án thì
khi mà em phân tích thì em thấy là thị
trường đồ cũ toàn cầu nó đang có xu
hướng tăng trưởng. mạnh dự kiến đạt 351
triệu USD vào năm 202 và người tiêu dùng
thì ngày càng quan tâm đến tiết kiệm chi
phí và bảo vệ môi trường. Ở thực trạng
Việt Nam thì thị trường đồ cũ phát triển
nhanh, đặc biệt là ở Hà Nội và thành phố
Hồ Chí Minh. Đặc biệt là đối với các bạn
sinh viên thì nhu cầu sử dụng đồ cũ đặc
biệt cao do hạn chế về tài chính cũng
như là cái nhu cầu sử dụng ngắn hạn. Và
việc ờ thường xuyên thay đổi chỗ ở cũng
như là môi trường học tập thì sinh viên
thường mua các mặt hàng như là sách giáo
khoa ờ bàn ghế các thiết bị điện tử với
mức giá phải trăng là giá rẻ. Đồng thời
ờ việc bán lại các đồ dùng không còn giá
trị sử dụng sau khi mà chuyển chọn hoặc
là tốt nghiệp để nâng cấp đồ dùng cá
nhân cũng là rất phổ biến.
Và để đánh giá để đánh giá được thực
trạng nhu cầu mua bán đồ cũ của sinh
viên thì nhóm em đã khảo sát 166 bạn
sinh viên ở khu vực hòa lạc.
Khảo sát cho thấy được ờ 58% các bạn
sinh viên thường có nhu cầu giao dịch
qua Facebook, các trang mạng xã hội hoặc
là qua bạn bè giới thiệu.
Nhưng mà kết à nhưng mà kết quả này cho
thấy các kênh ờ giao dịch hiện tại nó
còn thiếu tính minh bạch, độ tin cậy và
mức độ an toàn cần thiết cho sinh viên.
À
và có đến 39,6%
ờ cặp tình trạng là tin trôi, khó tìm
lại và ờ thiếu ảnh mô tả hoặc là bị ờ
khách khác so với hình ảnh thực tế.
Thì dựa trên các ờ à kết quả khảo sát
thì có thể thấy được nhu cầu ừ mua bán
đủ cũ sinh viên thả lạc rất là lớn và
phổ biến nhưng mà hiện tại là chưa có
hẳn một cái kênh ờ hệ thống rõ ràng dành
cho việc này.
Chính vì vậy mà nhóm đã đề xuất phát
triển nền tảng SL một trợ đồ cũ được
thiết kế dành riêng cho sinh viên Hòa
Lạc.
Thì nền tảng này hướng đến việc tạo ra
một môi trường giao dịch thân thiện, dễ
sử dụng và ờ với các tính năng như là
hiển thị thông tin rõ ràng, tìm kiếm
nhanh, tích hợp vị trí để thuận tiện cho
việc gặp mặt, trao đổi và có thể hỗ trợ
thêm chat giữa người mua và người bán.
Ngoài ra việc không tích hợp vận chuyển
thì cũng giúp các bạn sinh viên giảm
thiểu các chi phí ừ không không cần
thiết và tăng sự linh hoạt cho quá trình
giao dịch.
Một số web mà bọn em có tham khảo là các
web site như là chị pop,
ờ group, Facebook, FBU Hòa Lạc và ờ chợ
Tốt.
Về mô hình kinh doanh thì cơ hội cơ hội
kinh doanh đến từ việc ờ nhu cầu mua bán
đồ cũ của sinh viên Hòa Lạc diễn ra
thường xuyên và ổn định. Nên là sinh
viên mới thì luôn cần mua đồ giá rẻ
trong khi sinh nguyên cũ thì lại có nhu
nhu cầu bán lại thì nó sẽ tạo thành một
cái hệ sinh thái giao dịch liên tục.
Ngoài ra thì việc ờ sinh viên tập trung
trong cùng một khu vực giúp việc giao
dịch trực tiếp nó sẽ trở nên dễ dàng và
cũng tiết kiệm chi phí hơn.
về software production
về tầm
tầm nhìn sản phẩm phần mềm
thì SL đang hướng đến trở thành nền tảng
trung tâm cho việc mua bán đồ cũ của
sinh viên tại cơ sở Hòa Lạc ừ
nơi giúp giao dịch diễn diễn ra nhanh
chóng và tiện lợi và tin cậy hơn thì
trong tương lai nền tảng này sẽ thay thế
các kênh rời rạc và ờ bằng một hệ thống
có tổ chức hơn cũng như là thông tin sản
phẩm rõ ràng để tìm kiếm dễ theo dõi.
Score về major feature
ờ các tính năng app thì người dùng có
thể đăng nhập xác thực và dễ dàng tạo
hoặc là tìm kiếm các bài đăng với thông
tin rõ ràng. Hệ thống có thể hỗ trợ chat
trực tiếp để thương lượng giá, tạo giao
dịch ngay trong cuộc trò chuyện. Ngoài
ra có thể đánh giá người bán, thông báo
real time, tích hợp bản đồ. Bên cạnh đó
thì hệ thống cũng giúp kiểm soát nội
dung và đảm bảo an toàn cho người dùng.
về limitation,
exclusion là các tính năng mà chưa được
hỗ trợ ở phiên đoán MV hiện tại thì nền
tảng đang không hỗ trợ thanh toán online
và vận chuyển. Ngoài ra là cũng chưa có
AI để kiểm duyệt. Ờ và SL là ch là một
trang web cũng chưa có dành cho mobile,
không hỗ trợ đa ngôn ngữ cũng như là
không có post notification.
các tính năng đấu giá cũng chưa được
triển khai và cuối cùng là nền tảng thì
cũng chỉ áp dụng cho sinh nguyên FBT Hòa
Lạc đấy ạ.
Về future work tương lai thì hệ thống có
thể hỗ trợ nhiều phương thức đăng nhập
hơn mà nó không chỉ giới hạn ở mail FPT
và bên cạnh đó thì sẽ phát triển thêm
các tính năng tìm kiếm thông minh gợi ý
sản phẩm cá nhân hóa để cải thiện trải
nghiệm đều dùng. Nền tạng cũng có thể
triển khai quảng bá bài đăng để kiếm
tiền để duy trì server cùng với là hệ
thống kiểu duyệt thông minh để tăng độ
an toàn. Ngoài ra thì SL sẽ phát triển
ứng dụng mobile và mở rộng phạm vi ra
nhiều trường đại học không chỉ là JFT ở
Hòa Lạc mà có thể là trường đại học quốc
gia.
Về report hai là project management
plan.
về
phạm vi scope attribution, phạm vi dự án
ức lượng thì ờ
ừ bọn em dành 4
giờ một man đây là 4.5 5 giờ và với năm
thành viên trong 14 tuần thì tổng năng
lực của team là khoảng 315 m cũng chính
là tổng dự kiến của dự án.
Cho anh hỏi trước ừ
thế mình chỉ có mình em sẽ chỉnh được ạ.
Ờ
dạ
ở report thứ ba và thứ tư thì à với cả
mấy phần cuối thì các bạn thuyết trình
ạ. Em là người đứng ra nói tổng quan và
tiến độ cũng như là phân chia công việc
các thứ.
Ừ. Nghĩa là sau sẽ có tất cả cùng thuyết
trình đúng không?
Dạ vâng.
Ok.
về project R. Project RCK thì dự án có
một số rủi ro cần lưu ý là thứ nhất có
thể là thay đổi yêu cầu, thứ hai là xung
luật nội bộ, thứ ba là thiếu kỹ năng
ngoài ra thì ờ còn có các rủi ro như là
ờ chạy tiến độ, thành viên vắng mặt, lỗi
môi trường và mất dữ liệu. Thì để giảm
thiểu nhóm nhóm áp dụng các giải pháp
như là chia nhỏ công việc, theo dõi tiến
độ và sử dụng git docker để luôn có
các kế hoạch dự phòng.
Và ở dự án này thì nhóm chọn mô hình
phát triển phần mềm là thì mô hình này
phù hợp với các yêu cầu ban đầu chưa rõ
ràng có thể thay đổi liên tục theo nhu
cầu người dùng. Thì với kinh nghiệm đã
sử dụng nhóm đã sử dụng trước đó thì em
tin rằng phương pháp này sẽ giúp linh
hoạt điều chỉnh và có thể đạp đảm bảo
được tiến độ hoàn thành sản phẩm đúng kỳ
vọng
về à đi
về à thích testing.
Process of testing thì nhóm thực hiện
kiểm thử qua nhiều bước để đảm bảo chất
lượng của hệ thống. Đầu tiên là review
nơi mà các ờ thành viên có thể kiểm tra
và báo lỗi, đồng thời ghi nhận và theo
dõi lỗi theo mức độ ưu tiên. Tiếp theo
là unit test.
Tiếp theo là unit test thì nơi mà các
thành viên có thể ờ kiểm tra từng chức
năng sinh lệ bằng test tự động. Sau đó
là interation test thì kiểm tra sự kết
nối giữa các thầy truy hệ thống. Và cuối
cùng là system test thì ở đây là end to
end kiểm tra hệ thống từ đầu đến cuối
của luồng nghiệp vụ.
Đây là trending plan.
các công cụ như là Java, String Boot,
Git, GitHub thì bọn em có
dành ra là hai tuần và MySQL cũng một
tuần, IP testing hai tuần, RXJS 1 tuần,
Docker một tuần. Tiếp theo là ờ
anh thấy quay quay lên hỏi cáiing
plan này là cái gì không nhỉ?
À đây là các công cụ mà có thể là một số
bạn trong nhóm em không giỏi cốt lắm ấy
ạ thì à chưa biết được những công cụ này
thì bọn em sẽ dành ra thời gian khoảng
như này để còn hỗ trợ
ờ giúp nhau hiểu ấy ạ. Và tất nhiên là
leader của phần nào thì sẽ ờ sẽ dạy phần
đó.
Bạn Lê Việt nói đi ạ.
Cho em xin phép ạ. Tại vì là cái phần
chaning plan này cái chính xác ra thì là
do nhóm em nó không phải là một nhóm
chuyên về code theo cái chuyên ngành học
chính của trường thì nhóm em nó lại là
nhóm chuyên về bên tiếng Nhật hơn. Nên
là có những cái cái công cụ liên quan
đến code như là ờ như là React hay là
Doc ấ các thứ là bọn em không được học
đến và bọn em cũng ít được tiếp xúc ấy
ạ. Nên là cái training plan này bọn em
được lập ra là để cho giúp đỡ những các
thành viên trong nhóm còn có những cái
vấn đề mà mình chưa giải quyết được hay
là những cái khó khăn đối với cả những
cái công cụ đấy mà các bạn ấy cần phải
giúp đỡ thì bọn em lập ra cái training
plan này để là hỗ trợ cho các bạn đấy ạ.
Em xin cảm ơn ạ.
À
về các sản phẩm bàn giao thì report 1 sẽ
lộp sẽ hạn nộp là 24 tháng , report 2 là
24 tháng
cho đến report 4 là 31 tháng 3, report 5
là 15 tháng 4, report 6 là 20 tháng 4 và
cuối cùng là final project thì sẽ nộp
vào 27 tháng.
về phân phân công trách nghiệm thì
ờ thì ờ nhóm em ờ mỗi mỗi một
như kiểu em là em là leader của team
equipment analy team thì em sẽ người
chia được
to
cái này mình phóng to lên cho mọi người
dễ nhìn
ở nhóm em làm mỗi người sẽ đều đảm vị
trí leader ạ thì em sẽ là leader của
analis team bạn Ánh sẽ là design team
còn bạn An là de bạn Việt là test
bạn Tú Tú bạn Tú thì chuyên về forend,
bạn An là backend ạ. Còn document còn
doc thì hầu như là tất cả thành viên
trong nhóm đều phải làm. Nhưng mà em là
người sẽ giao nhiệm vụ và check lại.
Về tool thì technology sẽ dùng Java,
Stringbot, HTML, CSS, JavaScript, RZ,
Database sẽ là MySQL, AWS vân vân và bọn
em edit ở trên Visual Studio Code, vẽ
các framework ở trên Figma và
quản lý quản lý công việc các report ở
trên Notion các à và cũng quản lý ở trên
gira các a các spin spin và trên hub nữa
ạ.
Đ bạn Thiên bạn à từ này mình cũng giới
thiệu qua nhỉ thì hôm nay à tham gia của
chúng ta thì còn có hơn vài người mà
mình
có mời đó là Thiên Mạ Quân thì hai ông
bạn này cũng là một
một đ cũng có năm kinh nghiệm rồi thì
hai bạn đấy cũng sẽ tham gia phản điện
của mình nhá.
Dạ bạn
xin mời bạn Thiên.
Trước phép mình ngắt lời một tí nhá.
Kiểu cái phần công nghệ ấy. Bạn quay lại
cái phần công nghệ vừa nãy được không?
Ừ mình thấy phần text bên trên thì khá
ổn nhưng mà xuống cái phần ờ database
với cloud service ấy mình đang kiểu v ví
dụ nếu mà bạn đưa mấy cái này vào thì
thường thì mình nghĩ là họ sẽ hỏi bạn là
bạn đưa vào sẽ giải phải giải quyết cái
vấn đề gì bên trong cái dự án của bạn
ấy. Tại vì không thể nào mà cứ kiểu đưa
một lít vào thậm chí là có những cái
mình cảm giác nó còn trùng ấy.
trùng hoặc là hơi thừa
thì mình nghĩ là nếu mà nếu mà đã đưa
vào thì bạn cần phải hiểu rõ được là nó
sẽ giải quyết vấn đề gì. Ví dụ như kiểu
MySQL thì nó lo cho database đúng không?
Còn ví dụ như cái LLS kia thì nó đang lo
cho phần nào ấy nhỉ?
Kiểu dự án bạn nó sẽ cần đảm nhiệm
nghiệp vụ như nào thì mình mới đưa cái
công nghệ đấy vào ấy.
Thì mình nghĩ là nên đề cập được nếu như
bạn vừa đưa nó cả vào. Mình nghĩ phải đề
cập được.
Dạ mời leader backend ạ. Ờ đây bọn em là
cái RS này nó là một cái dịch vụ quản lý
My Cloud của HS ấy thì
nó có những cái tính năng như kiểu
scale này nó giúp mình monitoring dễ hơn
nó giúp mình bảo vật hơn khủ động ví dụ
như là bây giờ
ờ mình có thể scale đều được. Thật ra là
ra nó cũng chỉ là một cái
dịch vụ mà bọn em up cái anh đẩy cái
database Myel trên AWS để có thể quản lý
một cái dễ dàng hơn. Tại vì Cloud bọn em
đa phần là dùng AWS thì nếu mà dùng một
cái tài nguyên tập trung thì em nghĩ là
nó sẽ nó sẽ ok, nó sẽ ổn hơn.
Hóa ra là kiểu đây là bạn viết vì bạn
dùng nền tảng của IWS thôi. Ok. Ờ thế
còn cái FB cloud function thì sao?
Cái đấy là
thì hệ thống bọn em sẽ có một luồng on
job để gửi mail ấy gửi mail thì em sẽ sọ
qua thằng FB để nó scan cái que để
nó có thể gửi mail ấy
viết sọ qua đấy.
Cái phần gửi mail này thì anh Long anh
nghĩ sao? Tại vì em cũng chưa dùng thằng
thằng này này bao giờ ấy.
Em nó hơi lạ.
Thực ra là anh thì đúng anh bản thân
chúngng anh cũng thưa dùng tất cả các
nền tảng các dịch vụ này thì khó mà đánh
giá. Nhưng mà như bạn vừa chia sẻ thực
ra thì anh nghĩ là thật ra là chung thì
mình vẫn là một cái nhóm như vừa nãy có
đề cập một nhóm không chuyên đắn về code
nên thành ra là à hỏi về mấy câu về liên
quan về cụ thể về cái dịch vụ là nó sẽ
khá là
thực ra tại vì các bạn làm MVP thì em
nghĩ là nên ghi mấy cái co chính thôi
còn các bạn deploy lên đâu thì mọi người
thường
thực ra cái này cũng là để giút kinh
nghiệm luôn vừa nãy mình cũng vừa phải
note lại một cái đó là bạn ờ chính bạn
LER bạn cũng thuyết trình trả lời là vân
vân. Đấy mình rất rất hạn chế khi thuyết
trình nhắc đến từ vân vân bởi vì chính
mình cảm thấy nó quá dài hoặc quá nhiều
hoặc là mình nghĩ là nó không quan trọng
lắm thì mình sẽ trả lời vân vân là có
bao nhiêu cũng được hay thì ché nhiều
nhưng thực ra thế là sai bởi vì khi
nói như nào nh này thường à khi mà bảo
vệ này mình th ví dụ một cái điểm hứ
nhất nhá đó cái sắc tanh sắc tanh là
kiểu khi mà mình có một cái sản phẩm rồi
mình đem đi thuyết trình mình đem đi a
kiểu thương lượng để mà kiểu mọi người
tin tưởng vào sản phẩm của mình để đầu
tư chẳng hạn đúng không? Tất cả những
cái công nghệ, tất cả những cái việc
mình làm nó đều phải minh bạch chứ không
có chuyện mình nói vân vân. Đấy và mình
cũng nên phải nói là tại sao mình dùng
cái này các thứ thứ. Còn nếu không thì
mình ví dụ là mình vừa rồi mình nói là
giả sử là mình quen dùng
à AWS chẳng hạn thì nó tiện thì mình đề
cập vào nhưng mà ngắn gọn thôi cũng
được. Còn nếu mình ghi rõ như này là
mình đang giống như kiểu giống như cách
viết CV
mình sẽ ghi rất nhiều ra để mà tí khoe
là mình có áp dụng nhiều công nghệ nước
ra thì bây giờ mà hỏi rõ từng công nghệ
tại sao mình áp dụng mà thậm chí là tại
sao mình không công nghệ khác thì mình
lại rất khó trả lời được câu gấy thì
chính mình cũng không trả lời được mấy
câu mấy câu này nhá nếu mà mình dùng hết
thống kia ch mình mình cũng chưa dùng
đến được hết thật nên là các bạn lưu ý
không biết được các bạn thuyết trình ở
trường này các thầy cô có hỏi câu này
gắt không các bạn? Đấy đấy lý do mà các
bạn cũng phải tham khảo xem các nhóm
khác ở trên trường. Nếu mà các nhóm
trước đấy mà làm thế mà các thầy cô
chẳng hỏi gì cả thì thựt ra không sao.
Nhưng mà với cách hồi trước của mình đi
dạy ở trường thì mình đúng là mình sẽ
hỏi một cái này rất gặp bởi vì bởi vì
cái môn bảo vệ đồ án tốt nghiệp này nó
không phải đơn thuần là để cho các bạn
làm một cái phần mềm. mà hướng dẫn các
bạn giống như bạn Leader đang làm hiện
tại đó là nó là công việc của project
manager tức là quản lý một cái dự án thì
mình phải biết từ đầu đến cuối tại sao
mình dùng cái này, chi phí dùng cái này
hay mọi thứ là đánh đổi của nó là gì.
Đấy thì thường là mình sẽ phải cân nhắc
trong từng cái nên là mọi cái lời nói
bây giờ rất là rất là quan trọng để mà
tí thật ra là bởi vì thiên nói trước chứ
không thì mình cũng nốt lại mình tí mình
sẽ hỏi các bạn mấy câu này thì các bạn
sẽ khó trả lời thôi vì chính mình là
người nói ra mà đúng không? Đấy các bạn
lưu ý phần này chắc không sao. Phần này
các bạn cứ xem xét lại cũng được. Ok các
bạn cứ tiếp trình tiếp đi ạ.
Em sẽ nói về state diagram
thì sẽ có các nhóm người dùng chính bao
gồm get, user bioseller và admin. và các
hệ thống tích hợp bên ngoài bao gồm
Google SEO, FBAS, Vietmap và Mail
Servic. Với G thì người dùng chưa đâ
nhập có thể xem danh sách kinh đăng công
khai và thông tin cơ bản.
Ờ và user thì người dùng đã xác thực có
thể đăng bán, mua hàng, chat, thương
lượng giá, xác nhận, giao dịch và đánh
giá. Còn admin thì quản trị hệ thống
thực hiện kiểm duyệt, quản lý người
dùng, xử lý báo cáo và theo dõi thống
kê. Google so là để đăng nhập xác thực
người dùng. FBAS là để xác thực, lưu trữ
media và hỗ trợ real time
authentication. Vietm là cung cấp bạn đồ
định vị còn melovic là gửi thông báo.
Tiếp theo là về main flow thì bạn Ánh
này đấy.
Ừ bắt đầu với ờ cái flow đầu tiên đấy là
flow chính của dự án luôn là great
listing flow. Thì chi tiết của cái flow
này thì tí nữa demo thì chúng ta có thể
thấy rõ hơn.
Ở đây thì em sẽ nói đơn giản là cái flow
này là bắt đầu get sẽ đăng nhập vào hệ
thống sau đó xác thực số điện thoại và
đăng bài. Chị Hoa xuống đi.
Tương tự như thế thì chúng ta có ngoài
việc đăng tin ở trên thì chúng bọn web
của bọn em cũng có thêm một cái phần nữa
là về đăng đăng các cái post cộng đồng ở
cộng đồng thì nó cũng tương tự như đăng
tin ở trên thì nó cũng bắt guest phải
đăng nhập sau đó mới được đăng các cái
bài đăng ở trên team cộng đồng xuống anh
chị ho
cái luồng tiếp theo đó chính là cái
luồng mà admin sẽ à review các cái ờ tin
đăng hoặc là người dùng bị báo cáo và
giải quyết cái
báo cáo đấy thì admin cũng sẽ đăng nhập
vào cái ừ dashboard của admin này. sau
đó sẽ ờ xem các cái tin đăng hoặc là
review các cái tin đăng hoặc là người
dùng bị báo cáo và sẽ thực hiện các hành
động ví dụ như là duyệt hoặc là ờ từ
chối cái ờ bài báo cáo đấy xuống
chi tiết thì tí nữa sẽ demo xong
luồng tiếp theo đó chính là chat và giao
dịch thì à
chat ờ sau Khi một người mua mà muốn ờ
mua một món hàng đấy thì sẽ
chat với seller. Sau đấy họ có thể offer
giá, tức là ờ ừ muốn cái giá n đấy rẻ
hơn thì họ sẽ có thể offer. Sau đấy thì
người mua người ta sẽ chốt cái giao dịch
đấy. Và à
ờ người bán xác à sau khi mà nhận hàng
xong ấy thì người mua sẽ phải xác nhận
cái giao dịch đấy. Và seller tí nữa nói
này.
Kèo kéo lên trên cho anh một tí. phải có
cái phần đấy.
Thực ra đây là tính năng mà anh nghĩ là
tính năng cũng gần như là một trong tính
năng chính của các bạn.
Vâng.
Nhưng mà mình thấy là
đầu tiên vừa nãy mình dùng từ giao dịch
thì thực ra là như mình có đề cập là
mình cũng chưa thanh toán được đúng
không? Nên là giao dịch cũng sẽ là giao
dịch.
Nghe giao dịch thì cũng thỏa thuận thì
chắc đúng hơn.
Nói chung là nó là có một cái sự trao
đổi nhưng mà trao đổi kiểu nhắn tin thôi
chứ còn
Vâng đúng rồi ạ. Còn thỏa thuận hai mọi
thứ thì sẽ làm trực tiếp ngoài đời đúng
không?
Vâng.
Đấy thì thực ra là các bạn vẽ
đây gọi là gì ạ? nhớ cũng tương mở hay
từ thử nhớ là một cái sơ đồ để mà biểu
diễn về lâu các thứ như này thì theo
mình những cái gì mà không
có trong phần mềm ấy người ra là mình sẽ
không đề cập trong năm đấy bởi vì nếu mà
các bạn ghi như này thì giống như là các
bạn đang có sẵn về cái từ chối giao dịch
hay cái vân vân chấp nhận
có hết ạ
các thứ có trong phần mềm
Vâng ạ.
Không nhưng mà ví dụ là vừa rồi bạn nói
về việc là không chấp nhận về giá thừ
chối sẽ như nà
có có hết offer giá các kiểu. Offer nó
chỉ là mình đưa ra một cái giá ấy ạ. Đề
xuất kiểu
ơ nhưng mà đây nghĩa là offer ở đây
nghĩa là các bạn
Ừ thực ra là mình tí xem cái các bạn đ
dễ hiểu hơn.
Ok ok
bạn tiếp đệ.
À cái này chỉ là mô tả chi tiết của các
cái actor thôi.
Đây là
diagram là ờ dối này gì? Ừ
anh nhìn thấy không?
Ok. Ờ thực ra là cách để mà các bạn gọi
là thuyết trình cái uk này ấ thường là
mình sẽ
một lần mình tách ra hẳn với mỗi một
thực thể tránh việc để chung như này.
Hai đó là ừ vì nếu mà như thế thì các
bạn sẽ nhìn rõ hơn hoặc là trong trường
hợp này các bạn sẽ phỏng phóng to theo
từng thực thể đúng không? Ví dụ là theo
theo như mình trong máy chỉnh thì sẽ là
mình sẽ phải đi mình lại đi từ admin
trước cơ. Nghĩa là admin ví dụ giả sử
nhá admin là người lên a
lên các chủ đề hay các thứ này các thể
loại các thứ xong rồi à ư sẽ có seller
đúng không là người vào đăng bài, đăng
ký đăng bài sau đó thì mới có khách.
Khách thì ở đây khách còn chưa nối vào
cái gì không? Khách ở kia chưa nối
không? Theo từng cái đấy ạ.
À đấy thấy từng cái từ ạ.
Thế thấy cái ở trên kia vẽ một ông khách
chẳng nối đến đâu cả một ông seller ở
trên cũng chẳng nối đến đâu cả. À ông
seller ở trên lại nối đến block user là
như nào nhỉ?
Thôi
đấy
à. Đấy cả hai bên đều là seller
à. Tại vì nó nó dối quá nên là mới đáng
lẽ là không nên tách ra nhưng mà tại vì
nó dối quá nên là vẽ sang hai bên. Ồ
ok. Thế ông khách ở kia ngồi ngắm ông
seller làm mọi thứ thôi ạ.
Khách ở đấy nó là
khách đấy là kế thừa đấy ạ. À kiểu nó
user seller là nó kế thừa những cái chức
năng của khách này.
Con khách em lại để ở đằng cuối.
À nghĩa là khách đấy chẳng làm được gì
đúng không? Phải đăng ký xong mới làm
được.
Nó đúng rồi. Nó chỉ gần như là view
thôi. Chỉ xem thôi. Đăng
nếu mà xem thì nó vẫn là có tính năng
xem đúng không?
Vâng, đúng ạ. Xem tìm kiếm
trông cái đấy nó hơi loạn nhưng thôi
không chắc. Ok.
Nó chỉ bày admin
nhưng mà bây giờ kể ra
nhiều lắm.
Kiểu bình thường ở trên khi mà em cũng
xem hội đồng ở lúc mà các bạn thuyết
trình thì thường các bạn chỉ nói là à
đây là uscate diagram của admin.
Nói là uscate này là có tổng qua uscate
và nói qua thôi.
Nix qua thôi chứ chứ không đi vào chi
tiết từng cái chi tiết hết giờ.
Ok không sao là các bạn cứ lướt nhanh
qua cái đoạn này cho mình
cái list cái list tôi tôi l tầm bảy mấy
cái.
Thực ra nếu mà đúng ra thì bọn em sẽ nên
gửi tài liệu cho các anh chị trước để
các anh chị có thể xem được kỹ hơn về
cái vấn đề đốc của bọn em là bọn em làm
như thế nào. Tại vì thông thường thì hội
đồng sẽ làm như thế.
À thực ra thì anh có được Long gửi cho
tài liệu tất cả mấy cái này rồi. Anh
cũng tổng hợp rồi thì à thì bây giờ là
thường là bởi vì là hôm trước anh có hỏi
Long thì thực ra là cái cách bảo vệ của
bên mình cũng hơi khác so với bên những
hai bên anh Dực Lặc. Thì hai bởi vì nó
khác ở điểm là thường là các bạn sẽ khi
mà thuyết trình là biên khác thì sẽ là
in ra quyển à cái quyển tài liệu. Đấy
sau đó khi mà các bạn bảo vệ thì các
thầy cô sẽ ngồi nhìn vào đối chiếu với
cái quyển tài liệu đấy để biết được các
bạn đang nói gì ở trên. Thì slide thì nó
sẽ không bao giờ đầy đủ thông tin đúng
không? Đấy và đôi khi là nó slide của
các bạn cũng có thể lệch lệch so với cả
code, lệch so với cả tài liệu các bạn
viết ra. Nhưng mà trong trường hợp của
bên trường mình thì như Long có chia sẻ
thì là à các bạn sẽ gửi tài liệu trước
đúng không? Các thầy cô duyệt tài liệu
trước các bạn và các bạn làm slide sẽ là
một cái riêng để mà thuyết trình nên là
và cái người mà chấm cái tài liệu các
bạn lại là một người riêng. Thế nên là
cái hôm mà thuyết trình thì nó sẽ có
kiểu là cái ông nghe thuyết trình ấy thì
ông không hề biết tài liệu các bạn viết
là cái gì. Không không phải đâu anh ạ.
Dạ
ờ hội đồng là sẽ có năm người thì trước
khi ra bảo vệ bọn em sẽ là 27 này bọn em
sẽ nộp tất cả report trong đấy có cả
slide cho hội đồng thì tất cả năm người
thầy cô đó sẽ đều xem và đều cho bọn em
điểm ở đây là điểm làm report riêng nó
chiếm 20% còn điểm mình thuyết trình
trên hội đồng nó sẽ chiếm tầm 80%.
Ok. là các thầy cô đã xem hết rồi
à. Ok thế sẽ rõ hơn đúng không? Nên thực
ra là nó vẫn sẽ có nhược điểm và khi mà
các bạn thuyết trình thì
gọi như này không không nhớ được đâu. Nó
nghĩa là bây ngồi
cô vẫn sẽ có tài liệu trước ở trong máy
để xem để đối chiếu với cả so sánh ấy ạ.
Thực ra nó cũng không khác lắm so với cả
cái tài liệu khi mà in ra giấy với cả
tài liệu mà bọn em để trên đốc này đâu
ạ. Ừ.
Tại vì khi trình thì các thầy cô sẽ nhìn
vào cái slide và đồng thời là vừa hỏi và
vừa sử dụng cái đốc mà bọn em đã gửi để
tìm lỗi và gửi
là hỏi bọn em thôi ạ. Nên là cũng nó
cũng không khác cho lắm đối cái việc là
in ra sách.
Ừ đúng. Thực ra bây giờ mình sẽ thế phải
luôn in.
Vâng. Với cả trong
trong cái hội đồng đấy cũng có một thầy
chuyên về về xử lý những cái vấn đề liên
quan đến đốc tài liệu ấy ạ. thì thầy đấy
cũng đã là người chấm luôn cho bọn em ở
trong những cái đợt review trước rồi ạ.
Ok. Thực ra là anh thì anh cũng sẽ không
ngồi chấm tài liệu các bạn thì ra anh
thấy là làm mọi thứ cá nhân anh làm thì
chắc chắn là anh hồi đấy anh chưa chắc
làm được kiểu đầy đủ kiểu rất nhiều ý
như này nên là thực ra anh sẽ không chấm
tài liệu các bạn anh sẽ chỉ quan tâm thứ
nhất là các bạn cách các bạn thuy trình
này và những lời kiểu các bạn nói ra thì
nó nó có kiểu nó có chuẩn hay không thì
mình sẽ cần phải sửa lại điều chỉnh
Thôi. Ok. Thế các bạn cứ thuyết trình
tiếp đi ạ.
Cú thuyết trình về màn hình.
Ờ tiếp theo là về screen flow thì hệ
thống của bọn em có ba cụm luồng di
chuyển chính. Đầu tiên là luồng g luồng
thì từ landing page người dùng vào trang
fit sau đó có thể duyệt danh sách sản
phẩm bằng cách là hoặc là tìm kiếm sau
đó xem chi tiết sản phẩm.
Tiếp theo là luồng dành cho người mua.
Thì
từ trang fit người dùng
người dùng search từ khóa và sau đó là
vào danh sách kết quả để chọn xem chi
tiết món đồ. Cuối cùng là nhấn nút chat
hoặc là make offer để tạo à tạo cuộc trò
chuyện với lại người bán để đi đến kết
quả cuối cùng là có chốt hay mua một đồ
này không.
Tiếp theo là đến lồ ở lồng người mua thì
từ fit thì lồng người mua thì từ fit
người dùng sẽ seller sẽ ấn nút đăng tin
sau đó nhập thông tin sản phẩm và có thể
xem trước được cái
bài đăng mà mình sẽ định đăng lên rồi
cuối cùng là đăng tin và sau khi mà đăng
thành công thì người nhận à thì người
bán có thể theo dõi tin đăng ở trong
phần quản lý tin của mình và cũng như là
nhận tin nhắn từ người mua qua chat.
Ờ về admin thì à
sau khi mà đăng nhập thì admin có thể
vào trang Dasbo để xem các thông tin chi
tiết về hệ thống như là
tổng quan về hệ thống như là có bao
nhiêu bao nhiêu bài đăng và
những bài đăng vi phạm.
cũng như là có thể chỉnh sửa quản lý về
các danh mục cho hệ thống
và cấu hình của hệ thống.
Em xan
này dài đi. Em thử kéo sâu hơn nữa cho
anh xem. Kéo nhanh lướt qua xem.
À
đây là các màn hình
bên mình bắt buộc phải tài liệu kiểu chi
tiết này.
Vâng.
Bọn em bắt buộc ạ. Cái này thực ra nó
cũng là một phần của cái chuyên ngành
của bọn em ấy ạ. Tại vì do là sẽ không
thiên hẳn về code nên là bọn em cần phải
nắm rõ những cái quy trình nghiệp vụ
liên quan đến đến cái dự án của mình làm
để mà để mà thật sự hiểu là mình đang
làm cái gì. Các thầy cô sẽ hơi yêu cầu
gắt gao xíu liên quan đến tài liệu.
Cái này nó sẽ thiên về cảnh kiểu công
việc ba hơn business analist là phân
tích xong một cái tài liệu.
Vâng. Ừ
thường các bạn phải bảo vệ lần hai là do
cái report nó không giống với code đấy
ạ. Với cả report viết sai
đa phần là gì?
Đúng rồi. Chắc chắn là tài liệu thì cũng
nên kiểu lệch so với code mình không
chuyện.
Ok.
chuyển qua report 4 này
chỉ
này
alo
Bạn bị lag rồi anh ạ.
Ờ chị Hoa tắt xe cho em share cái này kì
cái này nó không nhìn rõ lắm.
Ờ cái flow hơn các bạn đợi tí chắc là
mình sẽ phải tạo nhanh một cái meet
khác. Thì cái mít này đang bị báo. Hình
như nó chỉ giới hạn một tiếng thôi.Ừ.
Đây chắc mình tạo nút mới luôn. Xong rồi
các bạn tham gia nhá.
Dạ vâng.
Th có gì anh gửi mic luôn trong này nhá.
Đợi tí tự.
Thế thôi
nghĩa này tự tạ lên thố này.
Đây
các bạn
Long vừa nãy em vào muộn
Long vừa nãy em vào muộn không biết các
bạn là Brit SD hay là ba nhỉ? Không phải
là dep làdit s ta
à đúng t. Ok các bạn chuyển qua link mid
mới nhá. Bởi vì cái này nó chỉ giới hạn
một tiếng thôi. Các bạn cứ chuyển qua
nhá.
Ok.
Cia tiếp đi ạ.
Đây ạ. Chưa có bản thèp nên xin trình
bày bằng cái này cho tí.
Thì cái flow hệ thống của bọn em sẽ như
thế này. Người dùng sẽ đi vào từ
internet qua root 53. Thì con root 53
này là cái gì? Thì nó sẽ là cái con mà
gọi cái phân giải địa chỉ IP cho người
dùng. Ví dụ như là bây giờ cái hệ thống
bọn em đang trên là đang trên domain là
SL.click thì nó sẽ hỗ trợ phân giải thì
người dùng chỉ biết chỉ nhập S click
thôi thì nó sẽ không phải nhập cái chuỗi
IP dài dòng của thằng này nữa. Thì cloud
từ cái root 53 này nó sẽ đi đến cloud
fund. Crow fund là cái gì? Thì anh có
thể hiểu là crowd fund nó là một cái
dạng có thể là dạng cách cũng được. thì
bọn em hot front trên một cái F3. Thì
bây giờ ví dụ mình ở Hà Nội đúng không
ạ? Mình Hà Nội thì nó sẽ
bây giờ khi mà người dùng đầu tiên mà
vào trang web của em gọi cái Cun này ra
thì bấm bấm load giao diện ấy ạ thì nó
sẽ cách vào con Crow Fun này nó sẽ lấy
từ
nó sẽ lấy từ Bit Gok ở Singapore và nó
kch ra cái điểm gần nhất ở cái khu vực
Hà Nội cho những cái bạn Hà Nội có thể
là truy cập cái cách này nhanh hơn, truy
cập cái trang web này có thể tốc độ
nhanh hơn.
Và từ cái fun này nó sẽ trỏ xuống một
con application los balancing. Thì tại
sao lại có con này ở đây? Thì anh có thể
nhìn xuống dưới bọn em có một cái auto
scaling group.
Thì bây giờ nếu em có cái này hai em có
hai con server backend ở đây thì tại sao
ờ nếu mà nó bọn em đang xét là con này
là 70% CPU thì nó sẽ kêu ra một con mới
thì làm sao để biết traffic nào mà nó đi
đều đến con này hoặc là traffic nào đi
đều đến con kia thì hiện tại có con cân
bằng tải đây thì nó sẽ phân phối traffic
về hai con server backend ở đây và nó
cũng có nhiệm vụ là check he check cho
những con server backend ở đây. Nếu mà
he check một trong hai con này fail ấy
thì nó sẽ scale ra một con mới.
Ờ ở tầng dưới xuống tầng dưới thì bọn em
có dùng cái dịch vụ là elastic cho
redit. Thì nó cũng là cái redit bình
thường thôi ạ. Nhưng mà nó sẽ không liên
quan gì đến những tầng kia cả. Nếu như
anh xem tài liệu bọn em rồi đúng không
ạ? Thì cái luồng chính của bọn em đấy là
luồng chat. Thì theo anh biết ấy thì
theo em biết thì cái web socket ấy nó sẽ
lưu cái
lưu cái nó sẽ lưu ở trên RAM đúng không
ạ? Thì nếu mà cái câu hỏi nó ra ở đây là
nếu mà một cái server back end này chết
thì sao? Thì RAM của con server backend
này thì nếu nếu mà một người dùng ở con
server thứ nhất mà người dùng thứ hai nó
sẽ nó bị server thứ nhất đầy nó sẽ bị
nhảy sang con server thứ hai thì khi đó
hai con server đó hai RAM khác nhau đúng
không ạ? làm sao web socket được thì nó
vẫn lưu vào database bình thường nhưng
mà ý là nó sẽ không lim thì đấy bọn em
có dùng một cái lc cho redit ở đây thì
nó sẽ hỗ trợ là scale hoặc nó hỗ trợ là
cách những cái để có thể sau phát triển
có thể giảm tải cho DB được. Thì ở tầng
dưới bọn em có dùng một con RDS ở đây.
Thì tại sao lại dùng RDS? Thì
RS đó là một cái dịch vụ của AFS thì nó
sẽ giúp bọn em là
giải quyết cái vấn đề là quản lý quản lý
tài nguyên và sao lưu và đồng bộ. Thì
những con này em thấy cái chức năng bọn
em hay dùng nhất đấy là
quản lý snap shot. Ví dụ là bây giờ là
đặt lịch cho nó một ngày nó stop
snapchot snapshot dữ liệu một lần thì nó
sẽ không thể mất được. Với cả là khi đó
thì nó sẽ hỗ trợ hỗ trợ cho em là scale.
Scale thì con này hiện tại là đang hỗ
trợ scale dọc thôi
nhưng mà nó sẽ đảm bảo việc chi phí bọn
em có thể quản lý được.
Anh nghĩ là chắc là em phải tạm dừng ở
đây đã thù gì. Th ra anh đang chưa hiểu
lắm. Không phải không hiểu cái em đang
trình bày mà không hiểu là ừ đầu tiên là
dự án em làm là cái đồ án này là năm
người làm trong bao lâu nhỉ?
4 tháng ạ.
4 tháng. Yêu cầu của cái dự án này nó là
như này nhỉ?
Cái thử ra vừa rồi là các bạn chia sẻ về
à
kiểu giới thiệu về cái dự án nhưng mà
cũng chưa nói cho anh là là cái kiểu đồ
án của thường thì sẽ yêu cầu những cái
kiểu như nào?
Dạ. Thời gian làm đồ án trong vòng 14
tuần thì khi mà kết thúc
1 tháng
14 tuần
à 14 tuần. Ok.
Vâng.
Ờ thì khi mà kết thúc thì
phải hoàn thành đủ vậy report trong có
cả các report về test và cũng phải hoàn
thành được ờ được web trang web hoặ
trang mobile và cũng song song là report
và code có phải trùng với nhau thì
không anh đang nói yêu cầu của một cái
sản phẩm các bạn phải làm nhá
kiểu tại vì mình thấy ấy không rõ Đó là
bên bên chấm ấy họ có yêu cầu phải xác
định được là bên bạn delo như nào không
ấy. Thường cái mặt này mặt sau thì mình
thấy là mọi người cũng không có tập
trung để ý vào đây đâu. Nhất là đây là
một cái MVP nữa. Ấ
tức là cái phần deploy này thì nó theo
kiểu là scale khi mà dự án nó thực sự nó
chạy rồi cơ. Nó có vấn đề xong bắt đầu
mình mới áp dụng vào để scale lên ý. Còn
nếu mà MVP thì mình thấy là MVP thì nên
là cái bài toán nó giải quyết được và nó
giải quyết đúng vấn đề. Nhưng mà mình
thì đấy là đấy là theo hướng thực tế
rồi. Còn mình đang không viết được là
bên bạn thì các thầy cô có yêu cầu cái
phần này vào phần nghiệp vụ không? Mình
đang khá là tổ mồ ấ vì vì như này nó
đang kiểu bị quá quá sức ấy.
Mình thấy các bạn học trong mấy tháng mà
áp dụng được tất cả cái này vào cũng
giỏi.
Thì thật ra là bọn em thì nói chung là
cái yêu cầu thầy cô thì cũng có thể là
chạy local hot nhưng mà ý là bọn em thì
ngành code cũng ít học về code ấy là
muốn mở rộng những phần này để có thể là
tự cứu mình. ạ.
Phần này thì mình thấy nó không thiên.
Tức là nếu mà để nói về một ba giỏi thì
mình thấy phần này nó không đúng về ba
nữa. Ấy.
Vâng. Cái này nó là về SA. Đúng rồi,
đúng rồi. Say bạn ấy đang hướng về cái
kỹ thuật hơn là bạn ấy hướng về code.
Đấy. Thì mình nói thế tức là một cái sản
phẩm thì nếu mà các thầy cô mới yêu cầu
là phải làm gần như là để chạy thật thì
thực ra nó vẫn chưa cần đến kiểu phải
toàn bộ biết về những cái này. Đấy. Thực
tế là cần chạy thật. nghìn người thì nó
cũng chưa cần đến mức độ như này. Chắc
là thấy phải có số lớn hơn thì mới nhắc
đến lot bing rồi các thứ. Thì chắc là
bạn An thì đang ờ thì đấy nghĩa là mình
đang muốn thắc mắc là yêu cầu của dự án
của các bạn nó là gì. Còn nếu mà các bạn
theo kiểu là đề tài các bạn tự nghĩ ra
này và các bạn cứ tự phát triển sao cho
là gọi là tự bơi đúng không ạ? để làm ra
một cái sản phẩm thì nó sẽ bị đúng là
hơi mất phương hướng nên thành ra kiểu
mình đang chú trọng là những cái mà mình
cảm thấy là nó không đúng của một cái
sản phẩm demo chạy thử của đồ án sinh
viên.
Bạn hiểu ý mình không ạ? Nghĩa là bởi vì
nhá ví dụ ờ không biết được các thầy cô
hướng dẫn các bạn sẽ như nào nhá. Nhưng
mà nếu mình hướng dẫn thì sẽ là mình sẽ
content về việc là nó sẽ là chỉ cần làm
một sản phẩm phần mềm là input output
như thế nào thôi. Tức là nó cần có những
tính năng như thế nào vân vân. Ví dụ là
nãy thì các bạn đề cập là mình đánh giá
là sẽ có vài tính năng chính như thế nào
đấy thì bây giờ lúc mà các bạn ngồi nói
về các tính năng chính đấy không phải là
bởi vì nói về cái này chẳng hạn thì một
dân kỹ thuật là người ta dễ hiểu. Nhưng
mà như vừa nãy mình nói giả sử là các
bạn đi quyết trình nó sắc tanh chẳng hạn
đúng không? Thì người ta là dân kinh
doanh người ta quan tâm gì việc là các
bạn đang sử dụng các công nghệ như nào
hay không không cần. Còn nếu mà các bạn
muốn trình bày rõ là tại sao các bạn vừa
nãy có nhắc đến công nghệ này và nó dùng
áp dụng để làm gì thì thựt ra như mình
đề tập một cái phần mềm đang code là để
chạy thường nghiệm thì cũng không cần
phải có phần công nghệ quá cao siêu.
Nhưng thôi không sao bây giờ còn slide
còn cái nào đằng sau nữa không để mình
thuyết trình tiếp về cái tính năng đi.
Chị share
Tú Tú share xong rồi Tú trình bày luôn
phần Tú
ờ
cái này của anh
này lướt qua đi Tú ạ. Nói ch
cái này có phải nói rõ không anh?
Cái này thư mục à?
Ừ kiểu chia các thư mục.
Cái này không cần nói rõ rồi l quá anh
xem.
Bây giờ anh ngồi kiểm tra code các bạn
có thư. Không biết là các bạn có dùng ai
code không?
Còn vai code.
Nhưng mà riêng về cái đoạn vừa rồi bạn
kia trình về hệ thống thì anh khẳng định
là cái đấy không thể vi code được. Được
có nghiên cứu rất kỹ.
Ok. Anh thử ra anh thích nhất cái vụ
database này này. Ông ông nào tự tin
thuyết trình về cái database này nhỉ? Em
Tú anh em nhở?
An An thí
Tú thoi hậu ơi. Tú Tú
Tú không rõ này.
Cái này cũng vai code để tạo ra vàng à.
code thì đúng rồi. Bây giờ có thể làm
được database rồi nhưng mà
đâu thì để thuyết trình được cái việc về
vụ database nhá thì các bạn để ý cho
mình là giống như vừa nãy mình thường
anh nói là nói nên nói luồng của một cái
phần mềm hoạt động. Tức là đầu tiên là
có admin này. Admin sẽ làm được những
tính năng nào tính năng nào thì nhắc đến
cụ thể luôn đến mạng đấy. Đấy thự ra
không cần phải quá chi tiết. Ví dụ giả
sửa dài bảng thêm sửa xóa bảng thể loại
hay cái gì gì đó thì không cần.
Quan trọng nhất là vừa nãy có các bạn
bảo các tính năng chính là đang tin
chẳng hạn thì là user nối đến bảng tin
đúng không? Thì bảng tin đâu cho mình
xem nhỉ?
Thực ra nếu mà hôm thuyết trình các bạn
hạn chế để hiển thị trông rằng giặc như
này như mình nói nhá. Các bạn có thể có
một ảnh tổng quát như này ok không sao
nhưng mà các bạn nên chia ra giống như
là cái vụ mà low của seller hay là admin
vừa nãy
thì các bạn có ba tính năng chính chẳng
hạn đúng không? Thì mỗi tính năng chính
thì các bạn chỉ hiển thị ra những bảng
liên quan đến tính năng đấy thôi. Các
bạn hiểu ý mình không ạ? Đấy thì các bạn
sẽ thuyết trình dễ hơn đấy và người dùng
người nhìn thì sẽ trực quan hơn đúng
không?
Các bạn Tú đang nói mình không nghe thấy
gì cả.
Ừ không không anh có nói gì
bạn nào thuyết trình cho mình cái việc
lưng cũng từ cái bảng đăng tin này đúng
không? Từ là đăng tin này những bảng nào
cũng thôi mình thấy có cả listing
history luôn. Xịn quá.
Chị Hoa vẽ mà đúng không?
Giờ sao bạn phải các bạn?
là ai làm em là c lại rồi
biết cụ thể từng bản thạ.
Ừ. Đấy thì bây giờ em thử liệt kê cho
anh bảng listing hoặc là listing history
này chẳng hạn đúng không? Hai bảng này
để làm gì nhỉ?
Listing là bảng của team đăng thì ở đây
có ID của bài đăng, có seller, có danh
mục và có kèm theo vị trí title,
reception, giá
trạng thái của bài đăng trạng thái ở đây
là có active
it
respon cái trạng thái
ngoài ra có create update
và có thêm trạng thái e giveaway là
trạng thái mà à cho tặng đấy ạ là price
của nó sẽ bằng 0.
Ok. Thế bây giờ ở đây mình thấy có cái
pick address id tức là mình sẽ cần phải
có một cái bảng là bảng kiểu address
đúng không? Bảng này nối ở đâu nhỉ? Mình
chưa hả?
Ờ nó là ở bên trên tú kéo xem có
nhỉ.
À đây đây
location name
xong rồi
ok có nghĩa là mình sẽ lưu lại một cái
địa chỉ đúng không? điền địa chỉ để cắt
thắng. Ok.
Cái bảng listing history đấy để làm gì
bạn nhỉ?
Chắc lịch sử sửa đổi này.
Đó. Thực ra là kiểu muốn vặn các bạn
thôi. Anh Quân ừ cái bảng đấy hình như
là để bọn em dùng để là lưu những cái
tin đăng mà kiểu mình đã sau khi mà mình
đã gọi là kiểu chốt được de với lại
người bán ấy thì mình sẽ lưu cái lịch sử
của cái giao dịch đấy. À không phải giao
dịch mà
lưu lịch sử trạng thái á hay như nào anh
chưa hiểu.
Hoa Hoa làm đấy mà Hoa nói đi.
Lịch sử đăng là
khi mà mình chốt de ở trong tin nhắn ấy
ạ thì
ờ khi mà xác nhận du thì cái status của
du nó sẽ là completed và nó sẽ đưa vào
cái bảng
ờ lịch sử giao dịch này. Và ở đấy nó sẽ
có hai trạng thái, một là hủy hai là xác
nhận. là khi mà seller và buyer đã bên
ngoài trao đổi trao đổi với nhau đã nhận
hàng hay đã làm gì đấy thì về buyer sẽ
ấn xác nhận cái giao dịch này xác nhận
xác nhận cái pin đăng này thì lúc này
buyer có có quyền đánh giá seller
à đây em đang nói về nghiệp vụ rồi anh
đang nói về cái bảng em sẽ lưu như em ví
dụ giả sử như em vừa nói là xác nhận
đúng không thì bảng này sẽ lưu bây giờ
có cột là trên by thì thay đổi V ai đúng
không? Chen tha trên đấy là lưu cái gì
em nhỉ? Có va bao nhiêu kia? Đấy nó sẽ
lưu
lưu giá trị là gì? Xong before state
xong rồi after state là nữa thì nó sẽ
lưu gì trong đấy?
Cái này vai code là chết đấy. Chim bu là
người thay đổi cái lịch sử thay đổi
đúng rồi. Cái đấy anh biết có mấy cái
cột kia đấy
trên là ví dụ như kiểu là
kiểu status trên hay là price update
kiểu update giá hay là update status ấy
thì
đấy thì before state là cái jon thì nó
là trạng thái trước còn
after state nó là trạng thái sau thì nó
cũng là cái từ cái trên time mà nó ra
thực ra thì kiểu ví dụ như kiểu như mình
ấ mình sẽ tò mò được ạ. Tò mò không biết
các bạn kiểu lưu gì vào trong cái before
state ấy. Trong cái trường hợp xử lý cái
nghiệp vụ của bạn Hoa vừa nói
ờ ví dụ như kiểu sau khi mà xác nhận đơn
đúng không? Mình không nhớ là có chuẩn
không
thì cái bảng này sẽ được lưu thông tin
gì đấy? Xác nhện đơn. Ví dụ như kiểu khi
mà xác nhận đơn thì cái trên kia kìa à
trên trên buy kia kìa thì nó lưu là
người mua hay là lưu người bán hay là
lưu người xác nhận. Mình đang chưa hiểu
là sẽ lưu ai. Đây kiểu kiểu bạn cần đi
vào cái chi tiết lưu ấy. Cả cái state
kia thì nó đang lưu cái gì ấy. Ví dụ như
mình thì mình sẽ hiểu là lưu cái listing
trước đấy. Còn cái after state thì lại
lưu thêm một cái listing sau đấy nữa.
Mình thì đang hiểu như thế. còn đang
không biết là các bạn có lưu như vậy
không thì mình muốn tò mò sâu hơn về cái
phần là cái bảng này sẽ được lưu record
như nào khi mà xảy ra cái nghiệp vụ ấy.
Dạ này anh nghĩ là bởi vì các bạn không
chuyên về tex nhưng mà thực ra như anh
có đề cập đấy thì tất cả các bạn đang bị
yếu phần này rồi đúng không?
Đấy các bạn sẽ lưu ý cái này cái liệu
các bạn có thể là ok làm các thứ các bạn
có thể theo xuống va nhưng mà còn về
cách viết thiết kế một cái gì đó cái a
ờ nếu mà các bạn thực ra không cần theo
về tex lắm nhá
à theo về bên a data analyst hay gì đó
các bạn vẫn sẽ phải nắm vững về cách
thiết kế hệ thống cũng như là thiết kế
về database.
Ờ bạn kia vừa nãy thì bạn đấy hướng theo
system đúng không? System thì cũng phải
để ý về database. Đấy, có thể các bạn sẽ
phải lưu ý cái này. Mình nhớ là đây là
một trong những cái mà mình cũng nốt lại
là các bạn tặng rất nhiều bạc.
Không biết là các bạn có bao nhiêu tính
năng nh nhưng mà mình nhớ là trong tài
liệu các bạn tạo rất nhiều. Thế nên là
đấy giống như vừa nãy là có rất nhiều
công nghệ các bạn áp dụng rất nhiều bạc.
Đấy đấy một trong những cái mà các bạn
đang khó trả lời thế nên là nó sẽ làm
cái các bạn lưu ý hôm bảo vệ phần điện
biết đâu lại bị hỏi thì còn biết cách
nói đúng không?
Còn cách nói như anh ví dụ giả sử như
bạn An nói vừa rồi cũng tương đối đúng
nhưng mà nó
hơi gượng tí về cái bảng history này.
Còn nếu mà em cảm thấy là không nói được
mấy cái này, chẳng hẽ anh lại kiểu chỉ
cách mẹo. Mẹo tốt nhất là những cái gì
mình không nói được thì mình sẽ cho nó
ngắn đi. Giống như là cái vụ công nghệ
kia thực ra em không cần phải liệt kê
quá dài ra. Bảng này thực ra em sẽ chỉ
liệt kê giống như anh vừa nãy nói là em
sẽ chỉ liệt kê những cái bảng liên quan
đến tính năng chính và em sẽ chỉ đề cập
đến thế thôi đúng không? Thực ra các
thầy cô nói thẳng luôn chính anh là
người đi dậy. Anh không thể ngồi đọc hết
code và không thể ngồi chạy khoảng test
các thế thì quá rõ để biết được là bây
giờ giả sử các bạn có khoe năm tính năng
nhưng mà hai tính năng không chạy được
thì chắc lại không đoán được. Đấy nên là
các em nên để hạn chế tránh việc là mình
nghĩ là mình cứ để nhiều như này là gọi
là dọa người khác. À gọi là dùng từ như
thế nó cũng đúng nhá. làm chỉ để cho các
thầy cô không hỏi nhưng mà chính thì
càng nhiều các thầy cô sẽ càng thấy là
cái này rối mắt phải hỏi cho nó rõ thì
mình sẽ lộ ra cái
cái không phải cái điểm mạnh của mình
thôi đúng không? Đấy, ở đây l kê nhiều
lắm anh thấy là có review inm kia kìa.
Nghĩa là diệt cả ảnh này xong rồi gì?
Xong rồi comment rồi hashtag nhiều lắm.
Vừa nãy không hề có tính năng nào nhắc
đến hashtag luôn. Chắc chắn anh vừa nãy
anh xem rồi làm gì có cái flow nào nhắc
đến hashtag rồi đúng không?
Có không hề đề cập đến mấy cái tính năng
này. Offer thì có rồi này.
L các thứ nhiều nhỉ.
Nói chung là bảng mình đang bị nhiều
không biết là có phải do AI tạo ra các
thứ nhưng mà mình có thể rút ngắn lại.
Mình sẽ chỉ nói những cái bảng mà mình
biết thôi được không ạ? Và nó liên quan
đến cái tính năng hồi nãy em đề cập nhá.
Ví dụ giả sử là chat này, ví dụ là
việc một cái bài đăng này đúng không?
Xong rồi chốt giá có thử thử liên quan
đến thế thôi.
Ok. Kéo xuống dưới tiếp nà.
Thôi bỏ qua phần database đi mấy ông.
Mấy ông l cây ra mấy ông có nói được
đâu.
Anh ơi chắc bọn em xin phép vào demo
luôn.
Ok. Ok các bạn demo đi.
Các bạn bắt đầu demo đi ạ.
làm
đây là trang
trang đăng nhập thì đây chỉ cho phép
những tài khoản nó thế
đăng nhập tài khoản tú đi
mặc định
FT
mặc định màu tí
ờ với tài khoản h FD thì nó sẽ hiện nó
sẽ hiện thông báo lỗi
nhập đấy
tối chứ là đấy đối với ngân công nghệ
không?
À đây là trang fit của bọn em ạ. Thì em
có tham khảo
ờ thiết kế của trang trap với cả
Facebook
thì em sẽ trình bày về demo về luồng
năng tin trước.
Ơ tài khoản này xác nhận xác nhận gì à?
Xác nhận rồi. Đúng vào cái tài khoản nào
mà chưa xác minh số điện thoại
có vào database sửa trực tiếp được
không? Có bạn nào có tài khoản database
cái này có anh ạ. Chờ chờ có
thao tác luôn.
Lỗi sự cố là luôn có một ông kiểu để máy
tính sẵn để ngồi sửa lần vậy các bạn đẩy
lên internet rồi mà các bạn thao tác dễ
chạy có phải chạy trên local trên chính
máy của ông nào đâu
sẽ ăn xe luô đi
đấy các Bạn cũng phải lưu ý cái này đúng
không? Nghĩa là home demo các bạn cũng
phải chuẩn bị hết tất cả tài khoản các
bạn phải test trước. Demo chuẩn bị
trước. Hôm nay chắc chắn là các bạn cũng
chưa chuẩn bị đúng không? Chắc là chúng
lắm chuẩn bị một tí tâm lý thựt ra các
bạn phải chuẩn bị hết đúng không?
Nhớ nhá các bạn hôm đấy phải demo các
thứ trước các thứ và lẫn cả phải xóa
database trắng trơn để mà hôm đấy vào là
coi như nó thứ ra trắng không cần trắng
lắm. hiển thị ra một vài tin trước cũng
được nhưng mà ý à phải test lại các thứ
và nên có cái a loại nhở bài đăng cũng
nên test trông nó cẩn thận tí nhá. Hồi
trước là anh nhớ là vài ông lên bảo vệ
như đùa ấy, hiển thị mấy cái bài đăng
linh tinh là các thầy cô dễ đổi xuống.
Đấy,
bọn em sẽ lúc mà khi mà bọn em demo lên
với các hội đồng giáo viên thì sẽ cố
gắng dùng những cái ảnh hay là những cái
thông tin từng bài viết có thật để bọn
em add vào.
Đúng rồi. Đấy đấy đấy. Nói chung là mình
mà thể hiện mình chuyên nghiệp đúng
không? Các thầy cô cũng không nỡ đuổi
cả. Thế
vâng không biết được các thầy cô bên em
có đuổi xuống không hay là cũng nói là
chấm điểm thấp nhưng mà thầy cô bên anh
là đã có từng kiểu lên 2 phút là đổi
xuống luôn rồi. Chỉ cần thấy tài liệu có
vấn đề hay chương trình có vấn đề đuổi
thẳng xuống luônấy. Bởi vì kiểu các thầy
cô cũng bảo hãy nên nhớ là tâm lý của
các thầy cô tức là cũng đâu phải có một
nhóm các bạn đâu đúng không? có nhiều
nhóm nên là cảm thấy là kiểu cũng khá là
mệt mỏi khi mà ngồi nghe nhiều cái kiểu
các thứ ấy.
Vâng.
Đấy cố gắng
bạn ấy bạn Long có bảo là hội đồng tới
các bạn căng lắng này. Nói chung là các
thầy cô sẽ tạo tâm lý chắc chắn là hơn
anh khẳn định hơn anh luôn. Anh nãy giờ
anh còn nói đỡ và các bạn các bạn kia
còn cùng nói đỡ các thứ chứ các thầy cô
thì có kiêng nể gì đâu đúng không? ném
các bạn và nhiệm vụ các thầy cô mà thầy
cô ném hết sức có thể bạn không bảo vệ
được. Ví dụ giống như vừa nãy có hai cái
anh đã đề cập đúng không? Đấy là các bạn
chưa bảo vệ được đấy đúng không? Đã bị
thử điểm rồi.
Các em ư? lưu ý là khi mà chuẩn bị bài ý
thì cứ mở hết các cái tab liên quan ra.
Cái thứ hai nữa là khi mà nói chuyện ấy
thì mình đang thuyết trình thì mình đừng
đối thoại như kiểu là bạn bè, một người
nói thôi. Và nếu như mà cần trao đổi thì
nhắn tin vào trong nhóm để các bạn cùng
trao đổi với nhau.
Đó, có gì thì mình cứ back cắt trước đi.
Sau đấy mà có vấn đề gì thì
cho một người nói thôi. Và nhớ là đừng
trao đổi rất là tự nhiên. Ví dụ một bạn
như lúc nãy là à kiểu nói chuyện rất là
vô tư với nhau ý. Lưu ý là khi mà mình ở
trong cái cái lúc mà mình thuyết trình
ấy thì thầy cô cũng sẽ chấm điểm những
cái đấy nữa các em ạ.
Vâng.
À đấy xin giới thiệu là hôm nay có cả
bạn Hter cũng ra nhá. Nên là các bạn
nếu các bạn chú trình ổn biết đâu được
việc luôn.
Từ nói xong nữa. Không
bảo nhắn tin cho các thế. Đây
có đang nói cái vừa rồi cũng đúng
ơ có thể dùng tài khoản anh Việt đi.
Thế giờ ta bị cách rồi bạn sao như thấy
nãy giờ đăng nhập lại nó vẫn vẫn vào
đúng không? H em bọn em đang edit DB mà
giờ đang tự
chưa vào được cái quyền đó.
Tôi vào lại tài khoản của ông
được chưa?
Tú đăng lại tin
à khi mà đăng tin mà l chưa mà chưa xác
thực số điện thoại thì sẽ phải xác thực
số điện thoại trước khi đăng tin ạ. Tiếp
tục
ờ
tiếp theo nó sẽ gửi OTP về máy.
TP là 350025.
Khi tác khi xác thực xong thì hệ thống
sẽ hiển thị thông báo thành công và bây
giờ ờ mình có thể đăng tin được. Và tối
thiểu à tối đa là đăng năm ảnh chọn năm
ảnh.
Rồi tiêu đề MacBook 2020 đi.
Sản phẩm điện tử công nghệ laptop giá
bán là 12 triệu.
sử dụng mô tả chi tiết ờ máy sử dụng
được 1 năm
còn mới ừ 98%
và
ờ cái mức chi tiết thì phải trên 10 từ
nếu mà mình dưới 10 từ nó sẽ hiển thị
thông báo trên Fe luôn
một từ nữa đi. Thêm một từ
không không cách ra nó mới tính là một
từ. Cách ra mới tính một từ.
Rồi
lúc này sẽ chọn địa điểm giao dịch
phường xã xã Bình Yên.
Ờ Tú se Tú gõ phim.
Khi mà chọn xong thì mới mở bạn đồ và
chọn vị trí được ạ. thì chọn vị trí ở
trường trung học phổ thông
hai vật trưng thực thất
ấn xác nhận.
Ở bên trái bọn em có một thanh công cụ à
một thanh để mình để biết xem là mình đã
điền đúng và đủ yêu cầu chưa. Rồi ấn
đăng tin ngay.
Khi mà đăng tin xong thì màn hình sẽ
hiển thị trang detail. Ở đây sẽ gồm có
nút có button ẩn tin, sửa tin.
Và bên dưới là có mô tả giá, có vị trí,
các tin giao khác của seller và các tin
năng tương tự.
Rồi tú vào một tài khoản khác.
Tiếp theo em sẽ review luồng
offer và chú Deal.
Rồi mình sẽ ấn vào đ cái chi tiết và sẽ
có cái nút trả giá ngay bất tường trả
giá ngay. Ấn vào thì sẽ ở đây có đề xuất
10% 15% luôn 15%.
Gửi đề xuất
lúc này nó sẽ hiện thị thông báo thành
công và đồng thời là sẽ hiển thị thông
báo cho seller biết. Ấn vào biểu tượng
thông báo và
sẽ vào tin nhắn.
Ở đây mình có quyền từ chối hoặc là chấp
nhận ấn từ chối.
Rồi thêm một à cái offer nữa.
Trên sá lần này chấp nhận
thì khi mà chấp nhận như này ờ cái
trường giá nó sẽ được xét vào trong bảng
de chốt đơn. Ấn vào chốt đơn
nó sẽ được xét sẵn luôn là 10,8 triệu mà
là cái giá là cái offer mà mình vừa xác
nhận đó. Ở đây mình sẽ thay đổi được
thời gian và địa điểm.
Ờ cứ cứ để như hiện tại đi. Sau một
tiếng để nó hiển thị thông báo về email
luôn.
26 thôi.
26 26 chốt đơn
ờ tin nhắn bên
lúc này thì bi có quyền xác nhận lại cái
du đấy đã đúng chưa và có thể ấn hủy
hoặc là chấp nhận.
Thủy ở đây thì trạng thái của du sẽ
chuyển thành detected. Còn chấp nhận thì
nó sẽ chuyển sang là completed.
Ừ. Thế nếu mà giả sử mà không chấp nhận
giá này mà lấy giá khác thì sao em?
Thế thì mình phải ấn hủy ạ. Và mình sẽ
một là Buer nó sẽ tạo ra một cái offer
mới. Hai là ờ
mình ấn ấn lại cái view chốt đơn đấy.
Em em thử thao tác cho anh xem.
Tú anh đi.
Điền à mười mấy triệu? 10 12 triệu 12
triệu tròn.
bao nhiêu cũng được cứ điền đi xong rồi
gửi lên
cứ phải ấn chấp nhận seller chấp nhận
rồi ấn chốt đơn
nó sẽ cập nhật 12 triệu
lúc này mình sẽ sửa lại được thời gian
và địa điểm
đây là chỉ khi mà chỉ khi mà seller ấn
sách xác nhận cái cái offer đó thì nó
mới đổi đổi trạng thổi đổi price ạ đổi
đổi giá tiền.
Ok. Cái thông báo kia cho vui đúng
không? Hẹ vui lòng hẹn gặp lại tại Hà
Campus. Rõ ràng em điền địa chỉ có liên
quan thôi nhỉ đúng không?
À cái đây là vâng đây chỉ là cái a mình
có thể dừng dừng ngay tại đây được ạ.
Nhưng mà nếu mà ờ buyer có nhu cầu đánh
giá seller thì seller có quyền ấn chốt
đơn và lúc đấy có quyền đánh giá.
À không ý mình là cái
cái địa điểm ấy không phải hòa lạc
campus đúng không? Bạn đang điền địa chỉ
khác mà
cái thông báo đấy là đang là fix khi fix
cứng là khi mà hoàn thành giao dịch à
hoàn thành cái việc chấp nhận chốt đơn
hay không thì nó sẽ hiển thị một cái
thông báo confirm này thôi ạ. Thì bọn em
vẫn đang fích cứng cái thông tin à cái
cái message thông báo
ừ ừ anh hiểu đấy ý anh thế ok
vâng đúng rồi ạ bọn em chứ bọn em không
không xét theo địa điểm
thực ra đấy là một cái vừa nãy anh định
hỏi đó là thực ra là em để bản đồ thế
thực ra nó cũng chẳng liên quan văn họ
lượt con tức là mình để ở đâu cũng được
đúng không đấy vừa rồi có
cũng chắc là cũng chưa kiểm tra kỹ việc
là bắt buộc ở Hà Nội giả sử thế
à thì cái đấy thì mình có thể quay trở
lại thử cái quá trình tạo bài đăng và
chọn cái thiện điểm khác thì bọn em có
làm những cái cái validate liên quan đến
vị trí rồi ạ. Thì chị Hoa có chị Hoa và
Tú có thể quay trở lại và làm lại những
cái bước đấy để xem là mình đang
validate những cái thông tin gì ở đấy để
cho anh có thể rõ hơn.
À không không anh đang hỏi thôi. Nghĩa
là
ok nếu thế thì em sẽ yêu cầu là bắt buộc
địa chỉ như nào nhỉ?
Lúc đăng tin ấy ạ.
Ừ đúng rồi. Lúc đăng tin có cái địa chỉ
để mà xác nhận giao dịch này này. Đăng
tin thì sẵn là ở huyện Thạch Thất á thì
mình cái xã mình có thể tùy chọn là xã
Bình Yên, Tân xã hay là Thạch Hòa. Đấy
là mình được chọn. Còn đâu là bọn em đã
ích cứng là ở Hà Nội và thuộc huyện
Thạch Thất.
Thế á? Nghĩa là chỉ trao đổi trong đấy
thôi đúng không?
Bâ bây giờ
tại vì của nó là quanh Hòa Lạc thôi nên
là những xã mà thuộc Hòa Lạc thì sẽ được
cho chọn
mà không phải không thuộc thì sẽ
thế địa chỉ địa chỉ là mình cũng sẽ điền
cụ thể số nhà hay mọi thứ đúng không?
Hay là chỉ cần ghi xã thôi đúng?
Ừ mình chọn xã và mình mở bản đồ lên và
có thể click cái một cái địa điểm nó gần
đến gần chọn mình hay là gần cái điểm mà
mình muốn giao dịch chứ không có không
có điền là số nhà bao nhiêu bao nhiêu.
Nó có dòng optional
đây.
Ừ đây anh thấy đúng đúng
đấy. Nhưng mà cái gì nhỉ? Đấy vừa rồi em
liệt kê liệt kê rất nhiều xã đúng không?
Đấy và thành phố Hà Nội là cả cái hiện
đại thất kia có thể ấn x h
nhưng mà thực ra chỉ một đúng không? Ok
rồi
xong rồi bản đồ đấy mà anh chọn sang
quốc gia khác thì nó vào lỗi gì không?
À có
đấy
chọn luô Trung Quốc
đấy em chọn ra biển chẳng hạn đấy
ra vân nam
được phải chọn xã trước thì mới được
chọn
ừ
xã đấy th
xem x
đấy kiểu thế xong rồi dận à em kiểm tra
em kiểm tra đấy kiểm tra như À
nó là theo tọa độ à?
Vâng nó theo tọa độ nó theo khu vực
thằng API phềm map
nhá. Nghĩa là em hot code ở trong đấy là
cái phần tọa độ các thứ mọi thứ đúng
không? Để mà cho anh chị n
em ghét từ API của map thôi ạ.
Này hơi phụ thuộc với API một tí.
Ừ thực ra là cũng tìm hiểu mà cái này
cũng xịn. Lần đầu anh thấy có cái kiểu
kiểu như này không biết về sau trường mà
thay đổi địa điểm thì các bạn ngồi sửa
code dễ như nào. Ok tiếp ạ. Ờ ok tính
năng vừa rồi là các bạn demo là tính
năng đăng tin này xong rồi có cả chốt
chốt de này đúng không? Thực ra là nó
vẫn còn à đúng thầy
gìạ? Ơ nhưng mà vừa vừa nãy là cứ người
dùng xác thực được là coi như là tự động
đăng bài à chứ không quan tâm được là
admin duyệt bài à?
À dạ không ạ. Đăng tin là auto admin
không không kiểm duyệt phần đó. Bởi vì
em thấy mà khi mà hệ thống nó lớn ý thì
có thể hệ thống hàng ngày có 1000 user
mà bây giờ đang tầm hai ba bài thì cái
số lượng tin tăng rất là nhiều. Admin
bây giờ mà duyệt tự động như thế thì rất
mất thời gian. Nên là thôi để cho các
bạn đấy đăng tin thoải mái đi. Xong rồi
mình bắt gặp cái trường hợp nào mà hoặc
là mình nhận được cái report nào thì
mình mới check và kiểm tra.
Đây em một ngày ngồi spam spam được bao
nhiêu team
một ngày có giới hạn một người đăng bài
không?
Hiện tại trong config admin là đang để
là không có nghĩa là tăng bao nhiêu cũng
được.
Phần đấy admin sẽ config admin sẽ giới
hạn được
bao nhiêu người đăng à bao nhiêu ngày
đăng thêm một ngày trong mỗi user
à thế
ok cũng là một cách
đây là giới hạn chung luôn đúng không
nhỉ ví dụ như là một ngày một người đang
bao nhiêu bài
dạ vâng
đây là giới hạn chung
ví dụ như có kiểu ví dụ người có nhu cầu
người ta cần đăng nhiều bài cần đến họ
đến trạm giới hạn thì các bạn có cái
phương án gì cho họ không?
Thì em nghĩ là cái đấy sẽ là phần phát
triển sau của con em có nghĩa là sẽ sau
sẽ quản lý về cái dòng tiền hơn. Thì nãy
em nói thì nhóm dùng khá nhiều tài
nguyên trên cloud các thứ thì tiền nó
cũng tốn ấ thì nhưng mà bây giờ thì hiện
tại là cái dòng tiền giờ đang chạy kiểu
nói với phũ rồi đang chạy bằng đang chạy
từ thiện thôi thì sau nghĩ là sẽ phát
triển thêm những cái đấy.
Cái ảnh này em lưu ở đâu nhỉ?
Đúng lưu trên cloud đúng không? Lưu S3
S3 đúng không?
Còn tính năng n nào nữa không? Em
có tính năng đánh giá.
Ok. đánh giá
chat
có cái báo cáo gì nữa demo cho anh xem
cái phần báo cáo đâu
ờ
anh anh vừa nãy à báo cáo kì ok
báo cáo tin lý do là
lừa đảo
Ừ được rồi vào sang admin đi. Đ căn
vào một báo cáo
đấy là vừa nãy là báo cáo tin năng
đúng rồi đúng rồi báo cáo bài
kéo xuống dưới
nó sẽ hiển thị hai button là từ chối và
ấn từ chối hoặc là ấn duyệt ấn duyệt
được sẽ có nút confirm lại nhận duyệt
lúc này thì user sẽ bị đánh gậy
thô nhưng mà mình muốn xem chi tiết cái
bài đăng đấy trước khi duyệt thì có được
không để mình Đấy nhưng không có nút để
nhảy đến
tin kìa.
À xếp chi tiết đấy.
Ừ. Ok.
Khi mà ơ Tú Tú vào xem có thông báo về
mail không? Có không?
Không báo về mail là bị bị ấy đi bị mail
meo của Long.
À
à đâu rồi?
Thôi không sao mail chắc là tính sau. Ờ
dạ
ừ
báo cáo này. Nói chung là mình mới làm ở
mức là đăng bài báo cáo.
Còn gì nữa không nhỉ?
Còn đánh giá.
Ừ đánh giá.
Quay chuyển lại cái lường hồi nãy đi. Ấn
chốt đơn.
Cái chat này là chat lưu ở theo từng tài
khoản hả em? Theo từng tin đăng ạ.
Tin tin à. Đấy thì nó vẫn gắn lên tài
khoản đúng không? Nghĩa là admin có đọc
được tin nhắn này không?
Không ạ.
Nhong trong database vào thẳng database
để đọc thôi đúng không?
Database à?
Cái này là em chưa nghĩ đến đấy.
Ừ. Nghĩa là thực ra là nghĩa mình lưu
hết trong database mà đúng không? Vào
thẳng database đọc được đúng không?
Thôi không sao. Ok. Ờ ấn chốt đơn chốt
rồi. Vừa nãy chốt rồi mà nhỉ.
Nãy là ấn hủy rồi ạ.
Ok.
Thì coi lại nick của ai nhỉ? Nick của Tú
à? Nick của Tú.
Ừ
chấp nhận thì Tú thoát ra và vào mục ờ
hoàn tất giao dịch.
Hoàn tất giao dịch hoàn thất giao dịch.
Đúng rồi. Lúc đấy là tính năng sẽ hiển
thị ở đây.
Khi mà mình ấn vào đã nhận đã nhận
nó sẽ confirm lại. Lúc này thì trạng
thái tin tăng sẽ chạ à sẽ chuyển qua là
show và mình có thể đánh giá được.
Đánh giá này để làm gì nhỉ?
Dạ thể hiện uy tín của
seller ạ.
thì tránh em thấy là nó sẽ tránh khả
năng lừa đảo cao.
Thế bây giờ anh ngồi spam một cái tin ở
lúc nửa đêm lúc admin không kiểm diệt
xong rồi anh dùng một cái nick khác để
ngồi kiểu cứ cho hoàn thành như vừa rồi
làm gì có thông qua ai đâu đúng không?
Xong rồi cung một đống hài lòng lên spam
gì đó. Bởi vì ở trong trường hợp này à
theo như anh đang hiểu thì là em sẽ cứ
có một đánh giá thì em sẽ gọi là tính
toán lại cái số lượng sao đúng không?
Chứ không phải bị thuộc theo số người
đánh giá đúng không? Một người có thể
đánh giá được một người liên tục được
đúng không?
Ừ. Vâng ạ.
Đấy nếu mà có giả sử đương nhiên chắc
chắn là các bạn chưa nghĩ đến bài toán
đấy đúng không? Nhưng nếu giả sử mình có
bài toán đấy xảy ra đi, nghĩa là một
người tạo hai tài khoản giả sử người ta
có hai email được đi. Đấy, người ta cứ
ngồi đăng tin rồi ngồi cứ đành giáo liên
tục lại bản thân để tăng độ uy tín. Thì
em các em sẽ xử lý bài toán đấy như nào?
Em nghĩ là đây là do hành vi người dùng
hơn bởi vì khi mà
anh anh hiểu ý có thể là mình bây giờ
mình có thể rút gọn là chỉ được đánh giá
trong một người trong vòng à
Trong vòng mấy ngày đấy thì sẽ tránh
được hiện tượng spam
trong vòng 3 ngày.
Ok, cũng là một cách
nói chung là đây cách kiểu hỏi để mà xem
biết các bạn xử lý một bài toán thực tế
ở như nào thôi.
Thì là em cái bài toán của anh thì em
chưa hiểu lắm là nếu như là kiểu là cái
thằng seller ấy ạ thì mình có hai tài
khoản đúng không ạ? Thì một cái tài
khoản seller là mình sẽ cứ tạo bài đăng
mới xong rồi tài khoản kia sẽ là cứ mua
xong rồi nó sẽ cứ đánh giá luôn là số
sao cao đúng không ạ?
Đúng đúng rồi đúng rồi
đúng rồi đúng rồi
chứ chứ không phải dựa trên một bài
đăng. Vâng
đúng rồi. Tạo nhiều bài năng vì rõ ràng
các bạn có duyệt đâu.
Mình mình tạo lúc nửa đêm rồi mình cứ
duyệt các bạn sáng ngày hôm sau úi giời
ơi kiểu một ông kiểu đang trăm bài mà lỡ
cả mỗi lần đăng bài là lên khoảng New
Feit mà tất cả mọi người sẽ cùng phải
nhìn đấy.
Vâng.
Mà thực ra là cũng không cần phải đăng
bài ngồi spam như thế. Anh chạy như con
boss kiểu copy cái clì rõ ràng vừa nãy
kiểm tra theo j thì chắc cũng không kiểm
tra theo kiểu quá nhiều quyền đấy. Mình
sẽ ngồi spam liên tục.
Vâng.
Ờ ph
thì ý anh ở đây ý nó
đương nhiên là hệ thống nào cũng sẽ có
vấn đề nhưng ý anh là khi mà em nhắc đến
cái việc là độ tin cậy độ tin cậy này
phải dựa trên cái gì đúng không? dựa
trên con người xát thực với nhau nó sẽ
đảm bảo hơn. Nghĩa là thường là bên em
kêu là mình là đứng ra trung gian thì
liệu cái độ tin cậy này nó khi mà anh
giả sử anh là một người dùng người mua
đi đúng không? Anh lên trang web của em,
anh tin tưởng trang web của em sợ anh
thấy bên em đã để cho người này đánh giá
là năm sao thì anh sẽ nghĩ là bên em đã
xát thực cái độ tin cậy của người kia
chứ không phải là giữa mỗi người mua và
người bán với nhau nữa. Bởi vì nếu thế
thì như anh vừa nói thì mua vẫn có thể
giống như là thực ra cái này tình trạng
chung của rất nhiều sàn giao dịch thôi
đúng không? Kiểu Shopee các thứ nó cũng
spam các thứ đấy nhưng mà bên nó vẫn
diệt các thụ đấy nhá. Đấy thì ý anh là
khi mà em tạo ra một cái nền tảng như
thế này, may nó chưa chạy thực tế. Chư
chạy thực tế là kiểu gì? Sẽ có người lạm
dụng nó. Như bạn Hoa có đề cập là nó có
thể là liên quan đến hành vi người dùng
thôi đúng không?
Nếu mà người dùng
kiểu làm thế thì mình có như nào? Bởi vì
lúc đấy mình sẽ không thể chối là cái
này các bạn tự đánh giá lẫn nhau mà mình
chỉ ở trung gian thôi. Không. Người ta
bảo là tôi là người mua, tôi tin tưởng
trang web của các bạn đấy. Đúng không?
Các bạn để năm sao tôi biết là năm sao
thôi. Đấy. Vâng. Thì để về giải quyết
cái vấn đề này thì em nghĩ là nó sẽ là
một cái về saucope bọn em sẽ cố gắng xử
lý thêm. Ví dụ như là bọn em sẽ ờ ngăn
những cái tài khoản mà vừa mới xác thực
đăng bài liên tục trong vòng một khoảng
thời gian cố định là bao lâu đấy. Và bọn
em sẽ tạo thêm những cái rule mới cho
cái hệ thống để nó hoàn thiện hơn và nó
chắc chắn hơn về cái vấn đề này. Tại vì
là bọn em bây giờ với những cái vấn đề
như này thì bọn em chỉ có thể là giảm
thiểu rủi ro từ những cái cuộc giao dịch
mà nó mang tính lừa đảo như này thì chứ
thực ra là cũng không thể chặn được hết
hoàn toàn nên là bọn em sẽ cố gắng để mà
ừ xử lý và làm cho cái vấn đề nó nó ảnh
hưởng ở mức nhỏ bé nhất ạ. Ok
được đấy. Đấy các bạn anh bảo rồi chắc
chắn là khi bảo vệ đồ án là chắc chắn
thầy cô sẽ ném đá những cái trường hợp
mà rất oái ăm như thế. Các bạn cứ tự tin
trả lời thế là được.
Thế không sao đâu. Thấy thế là được đấy.
Không phải là một cái trừ điểm đâu.
Chỉ khi như vừa nãy tôi nói đấy. Vẫn về
cái vụ kia khi các bạn không nói được gì
thì lúc đấy nó sẽ kiểu bị đánh giá. Nh
bạn lưu ý nhá. Vâng. Vâng. Vâ em cảm ơn
ạ.
À có các bạn khác có muốn hỏi thêm gì
không ạ?
Thực ra thì cái dự án này thì em thấy nó
vẫn chưa liên quan đến phần dòng tiền
lắm nhưng là một vấn đề nó cũng chưa có
đến mức đạt để họ hỏi.
Cái này cũng có giao dịch ngoài đời đấy.
Chẳng qua là mình x thực mọi thứ qua
mạng thôi. Thực ra mình xác thực sa đấy
mình kiểu giao dịch trực tiếp chứ không
phải là mình sẽ kiểu như là mình được
cái bên mà kiểu xác thực điều đấy. Bây
giờ để hai bên kia xác thực đồng ý.
Ừ nhưng mà mình vẫn để người dùng là đấy
ở đây là rất hài lòng này. Xong rồi các
thứ là sản phẩm như mô tả vân vân vân
tin tưởng đấy. Xong rồi lúc về sau lỗi
xong rồi lúc sau ông ấy scam ông ấy bán
cho cái laptop không chạy được không mất
tích đúng không? Không kiện đâu cả.
Ờ về cái vấn đề là khi mà mọi người bảo
là cái hệ thống bọn em ấy thì thực ra
nếu mà nhìn vào ngay từ ban đầu là nó sẽ
giống với cả một số những cái ví dụ đã
có sẵn trên mạng. Ví dụ như là thằng trợ
tốt nhưng thằng trợ tốt là nó cũng nó
cũng là một cái trợn thông tin là kiểu
mọi người có thể đăng tin lên là mình
đang cần cái này, mình muốn bán cái này,
mình đang mình đang có nhu cầu về cái
cái này thì mình nên tìm ở đâu hay là có
ai bán cho mình hoặc mình bán cho ai đấy
thì nó sẽ là một cái trợ thông tin thôi
ạ. Thì như cái hệ thống của bọn em này
thì nó cũng giống như trợ tốt là nó sẽ
dừng lại ở cái mức là đi bằng lời nói
với nhau khoa mạng và họ họ những cái
những cái người dùng sẽ là những cái
người mà có thể là tự đến và trao đổi
hàng hóa với nhau. Nên là khi mà bọn em
làm ra cái đánh giá cuối cùng này thì
bọn em thực ra cũng lúc đấy cũng đã nghĩ
rất nhiều là
nếu mà mình làm cái đánh giá như này thì
nó có hợp lý không? Tại vì là vốn cái
luồng mua bán nó đã chưa kết thúc ở cái
de bằng mồm, de bằng chat ở trên trên hệ
thống như này mà thực ra đáng ra nó phải
kết thúc khi mà tiền trao cháo ú là
đồ đưa cho nhau và tiền đưa cho nhau rồi
và họ đã hài lòng rồi. Nên là bọn em à
khi mà bọn em làm ra cái này thì bọn em
cũng cũng chỉ nghĩ về cái suy nghĩ ban
đầu là bọn em tạo cái đánh giá để cho là
những người người ta dùng xong thì người
ta thấy hài lòng về cái cuộc trao đổi
đấy thì họ có thể lên họ đánh giá và họ
xây dựng những cái cộng đồng mà nó ổn
định hơn. Nó là cái đánh cái cái đóng
góp từ mọi người và cho cái cộng đồng
thôi ạ. Ok. Thực ra là anh định hỏi thêm
hai cái thôi nhưng mà thấy là hôm nay
cũng muộn rồi. Mí lại yêu cầu thêm
lại thêm thôi. Chắc là hôm nay mình cạm
vào đây cũng được. Có gì là mình anh sẽ
gửi lại cái video này cho các bạn thấy
kiểu nói chung là thấy cần hỏi thêm này
hay cần trao đổi thêm cái gì đó thì vẫn
có thể nắm trao đổi qua anh và qua Long
nhá. Đấy xin cảm ơn tất cả mọi người ạ.
Vâng cảm ơn anh chị. Cảm ơn mọi người.
Chào các
bạn
ạ. Mọi người mọi người